[музика]
привіт і Ласкаво просимо до Європи У
фокусі Ми раді що ви приєдналися до нас
несебна спека вдарила по півню Європи в
умовах посухий температури понад 40
градусів за Цельсієм будь-яка Іскра може
спричинити пожежу
цю руку Іспанія вже зіткнулася з
сильними лісовими пожежами відсутність
дощів і багаторічна постійно посуха
різко збільшили кількість операцій
засідання пожеж пожежним бригадам
доведеться інтенсивно попрацювати адже
наближається основний сезон лісових
пожеж
тепер від таких людей як енріх сапекс
залежить чи вдасться запобігти
виникненню великих пожеж він ходить до
складу спеціального підрозділу і він
напоготові
ліси в Іспанії втратили значну частину
своєї природної захисної сили
зміна клімату значно зменшила популяцію
дерев в Україні
Ось чому в таких лісих регіонах як
Каталонія вживається багато заходів для
підвищення стійкості лісів
дороги Софії вкриті пилом Ми дуже
спекотно 35 градусів за Цельсієм
енрік сапа зі своїм спеціальним
підрозділом обстежує каталонські ліси
аби запобігти лісовим
[музика]
стойка стає все сильнішою і частішою ми
можемо спробувати зупинити поширення
пожеж лише спостерігаючи та швидко
реагуючи на них
у першій половині 2023 року згоріло
майже 70 тисяч гектарів лісу це
територія більша за весь Мадрид із усіх
земель спалених лісовими пожежами в ЄС
більше половини припадає на Іспанію
енрік дуже стурбований він перевіряє
грунт на вологість і бачить один і той
же результат він сухий навіть глибоко
під поверхнею це означає що пожежа може
спалахнути будь-якої миті тому вони
повинні діяти
на франха де протекціон ми створили тут
стратегічну захисну смугу і вичистили
усі чагарники з лісу
спалахне вона не зможе поширитися і не
зможе досягти верхівок дерев
для порівняння Ось там ми залишили все
так як було
пожежники на станції також постійно
напоготові за найменших ознак лісової
пожежі вони виїжджають на місце Емілі
далмау спеціалізується на таких
надзвичайних ситуаціях Він каже що
екстремальний кліматичні умови
виснажують ліси
щоб вона парти моря його рослини дуже
страждають
деякі з них гинуть інші втрачають
біомасу А це створює більше палива для
лісових пожеж
якщо пожежа починається у таких умовах
вона стає ще більш руйнівною від самого
початку
наприкінці червня у сільській місцевості
навколо та рагу не спалахнула пожежа
пожежники боролися з полум'ями з повітря
і на землі
Емілі спостерігав за операцією зі
станції
загорівся комбайн і підпалив поле звідти
полум'я швидко перекинулося на сусідній
ліс
спецпідрозділ проводить регулярне
повітряне спостереження у тому числі і
за лісу заготівли а енрік відправляє на
поля пожежні машини про всяк випадок
збирання врожаю небезпечне адже
відбувається у спекотну пору року коли
пожежа може спалахнути будь-якої миті
тому ми тримаємось поруч щоб мати змогу
швидко реагувати і гасити будь-які
пожежі
[музика]
фермери вдячні пожежникам за те що вони
поруч
Томас сарі побував у двох небезпечних
ситуаціях але йому вдалося вчасно
загасити вогонь власними силами
раптово з вихлопної труби пролунав вибух
її скраб полетіли на сіно яке залишилося
на машині і тоді спалахнуло пожежу
пожежники очікують що в майбутньому буде
іще важче Емілі вважає що головна
причина цього Кліматичні зміни
спек робить атмосферу все більш
нестабільною це призводить до збільшення
швидкості вітрів
а ці вітри призводять до того що пожежі
стають набагато більш руйнівними ніж
зазвичай
його команда із профілактики також
стурбовані впливом людства на клімат
вони кажуть що однієї лише профілактики
недостатньо і терміново потрібні більш
ефективні політичні
заходив
Світ змінюється ліси горять скрізь
усвідомити що ми не можемо залишити
нашим дітям таку спадщину випалену землю
виснажений ліс пережили ще один
спекотний і сухий день завтра енріх та
його команда знову вирушать на завдання
аби спробувати запобігти найгіршому
розвитку подій
кілька тижнів в тому ми познайомили вас
з Єгором українським солдатом він воює з
російськими окупантами на передовій Він
отримав поранення і втратив ногу згодом
повернувся до свого підрозділу уже з
протезом ігор не сумнівається У
правильності своїх дій він прийняв
пропозицію з Норвегії на ще краще протез
адже це має зробити бійця ще швидшим на
полі бою зараз Єгор проходить лікування
неподвіг столиці Норвегії Осло і мрії
якнайшвидше повернутися до своїх
побратимів
під час прогулянки на каное озером у
Норвегії Єгор та Діма відчувають себе
дуже далеко від війни в Україні але у
їхніх думках Вона все ще дуже близько
навіть тут у реабілітаційному центрі
вони обидва втратили ноги воюючи на
фронті в Україні Незважаючи на це Єгор
планує незабаром повернутися на війну
Взагалі вже після цього вже справді не
боюся в принципі вже те що пройшов вже
нічого страшного не побачив ну тільки
якщо там щось друге не отрує руку ногу
то там може вже потім задумується
Ну да коли вже другий раз сюди приїде
тоді може я вже задумаю це вже буде отак
сидіти Так будуть всі хотіти
для 39-річного дім Ми жарти це один із
способів впоратися з пережитим він
прийняв рішення не повертатися
проходить час і вже Ну адаптуйся в цьому
житті
в цивільному в мене є ще син якого
потрібно виростити Потрібно цю війну
трохи відпустити
але для 20-річного Єгора війна все що
залишається вирішальним фактором У його
житті уперше ми познайомилися із ним у
травні на сході України Це мабуть
лепесток був касети перескидували і я
наступив упав не зрозумів що до чого
дивлюсь на ногу а там нема Просто її
немає там все отаке розкрити було п'ятка
в одній Стороні
його гомілку не вдалося врятувати
наступні 7 місяців Він провів у лікарні
Єгор довелося вчитися ходити із протезом
всупереч порадам лікарів та наполяганням
рідних Він вирішив повернутися на фронт
тут у Норвегії фахівці намагаються
зробити для нього більше
його розробили новий протест який
забезпечує ширший діапазон рухів
цим протезом згинається
тут більше ароматизації йде і у мене не
йде удар в кістку тобто в мене все
чудово
Єгор і Діма пробудуть 5 тижнів у цій
клініці розташовані приблизно за 100
кілометрів на північ від Осло незважаючи
на мовний бар'єр їх тепло приймають
норвезькі колеги пацієнти
їм тут комфортно
а це кому-то два різних світи А що там
війна тута ми все спокійно Все тихо там
було такі хаос
зміни пішли їм на користь дні у клініці
насичені силовими тренуваннями та
гімнастикою серед іншого
терапевти зосереджуються на особливих
потребах солдатів
для старшої людини наприклад може бути
важливіше мати можливість подбати про
себе виконувати прості речі такі як
відвідування туалету Підйом по сходах
або Похід за покупками для солдатів
важливіше те як вони можуть пересуватися
на полі бою тому ми підібрали більш
складні вправи те що ви зараз бачите не
схоже на наші звичайні заняття з
пацієнтами з ампутаціями
Єгор показує значний прогрес а от Діма
новим протезом незадоволений
це куксиприйомник він мені трохи не
підходить зразу одягнув вроді підійшов
але доїхали сюди почала боліти нога
український мені підігнали і він трохи
ну підходить мені я можу в ньому цілий
день знаходитись
лікарі кажуть що може допомогти Ще одна
операція Але у хлопця інші плани Він
збирається повернутися додому отримати
офіційну виписку і шукати роботу
Єгор у свою чергу повернеться до свого
підрозділу на Донбас Він підтримує
постійний зв'язок із побратимами та
матір'ю
да здорова
вдома Що там розкажіть
спочатку Мати була проти того щоб її
єдиний син повертався на війну але зараз
родина змирилася із цим рішенням
мабуть з обов'язок кожного чоловіка
нашій країні не ховатися А якщо буде
більше таких як
його друзі побратими то ми скоріше
повернемося у нас буде мир тому для нас
він герой Ми підтримуємо завжди як у нас
немає вибору скажемо так
у її сина був вибір Він міг залишатися у
Норвегії вчитися працювати І будувати
нове життя для себе
але він повертається на українську землю
до своїх товаришів до всіх перед ким
Єгор відчуває свій обов'язок незважаючи
на те які жертв це йому коштувало
наприкінці червня у Франція охопили
масові заворушення вони були виховані
смертю на Хеля французького підлітка з
міграційним походженням
билася 18-річного хлопця під час
дорожнього контролю нантері на околиці
Парижа
Лють особливо з боку мешканців
передмість була спрямована на державу та
її виконавчий орган поліцію
також загинув під час поліцейської
перевірки які багато французів чоловік
дивується чому в поліції є проблеми з
насильством і расизмом
коктейлі Молотова що летять у бік
поліції підпали автобусів мародерство
кілька днів поспіль заворушення
поширюється по всій Франції
масові заворушення почалися після того
як 17-річного нахеля застрелив
поліцейські під час патрулювання у
нантері передмісті Парижа
пізніше поліцейський стверджував що
автомобіль рухався на нього але
відеозаписи доводять що це не так на них
видно що йому не загрожувала небезпека
коли він стріляв
цей випадок було знято на камеру на
відміну від десятків інших випадків
поліцейського насильства спрямованого у
першу чергу проти мешканців бан’є
околиць міста
як наприклад випадок мегді бухута з
Ліона для своєї сім'ї він став ще однією
жертвою поліцейського насильства які на
Хеля його застрелили під час
поліцейської перевірки
це він коли йому було 4 роки і він ходив
до дитячого садка це він у 6 років із
нашим батьком
магді долучився до банди ще підлітком
його було засуджено за крадіжку і він
провів деякий час у в'язниці
він ніколи нікого не вбивав він робив
помилки крав але він ніколи не вдавався
до надмірного насильства ніколи нікого
не вбивав
рідні магді ведуть нас на автостоянку де
Поліція зупинила його у 2015 році
випадково помітивши
він не повернувся до в'язниці після
умовно-дострокового звільнення Мій брат
їхав на першій передачі він намагався
пройти повз них але поліцейський підбіг
з боку і двічі вистрілив у нього
поліцейський 5 разів змінював свої
свідчення зрештою йому довелося визнати
що він стріляв з боку і що він не діяв з
метою самозахисту другий постріл вбив
медіа
вирок у суді ще не винесено
кількість випадків насильства з боку
поліції у Франції зростає з 2017 року
коли було прийнято закони які надав
поліції більше повноважень під час
зупинки транспорту дослідження показують
що ризик померти під час поліцейської
перевірки у Франції втричі вище ніж у
Британії
міністр внутрішніх справ Франції
дарманен визнає що недоліки є
поліцейські теж припускаються помилок
але ми також маємо забезпечити їм краще
і довше навчання
поліцейський абдуло є канте звертається
до мешканців передмісті які часто
заснували соціальної депривації протягом
десятиліть у передмістях часто проживає
більше іммігрантів Він використовує
відео та коментарі у соціальних мережах
щоб подолати розбіжності та пояснити
позицію поліції
жодним поліцейський не прокидається
вранці з бажанням когось убити але в
деяких районах особливо там де живе
багато емігрантів рівень злочинності
високий ми не патрулюємо вулиці просто
так місцеві жителі хочуть щоб поліція
була присутньою
деякі французькі соціологи стверджують
що певні райони перетворилися на гетто
держава підвела своїх мешканців вважає
Мішель кокорев
колоніаль і у цьому є колоніальний
контекст
деякі передмістя нагадують французькі
колонії оскільки мешканців постійно
контролює поліція
тобто існує расове профілювання та
приниження
ось уже 8 років міряв і хаміт бухута
борються за те щоб поліцейського який
убив їхнього брата було засуджено
[музика]
При цьому вони виступають проти масових
заворушення
мирні протести - це краще ніж палити
машини невинних людей
між передмістями і поліцією французької
держави пролягає глибокий розкол
здається що насильство може знову
спалахнути будь-якої миті
після брексу у 2020 році британський
фермер такий як кімберц зіткнулися з
великою проблемою їм просто не вистачає
робітників для збору врожаю вихід
Великобританії з Європейського Союзу
призвів до дефіциту іноземної і зазвичай
дешевшої робочої сили
багато британців вважають таку роботу
надто важкою і низькооплачуваною
британська економіка досі бореться з
наслідками брексіту і ось дані нещодавно
опитування понад 50% британців
проголосували б за те щоб знову
приєднатися до Європейського Союзу
чи справді можливо у Великобританії
зібрати врожай полуниці без дешевої
робочої сили із країн з низькою
заробітною платою як це пропагували і
обіцяли прихильники бредсіту
адже цю ягоду мали б збирати британці за
високі зарплати але фермер цім чемберс
стару модний на його полях працюють
болгари індонезійці та казахи за 12 євро
на годину
Якщо ви хочете щоб ця людина отримувала
високу зарплату то будь ласка платіть
мені більше грошей у супермаркетах і я
буду платити їм хоч по 100 тисяч фунтів
але цього не буде ми намагалися останні
10 років заохоти та англійців знову йти
працювати на фермі
проблема фермера Тіма в тому що він не
може знайти достатньо робітників за
кордоном
британський уряд хочу впускати менше
мігрантів а не більше
наразі дозволів на роботу видано на 10
тисяч менше ніж потрібно
вони не видавали дозволи на роботу поки
сезон уже не розпочався А це занадто
пізно Тож нам потрібно гнучкість щоб
привести людей раніше Вони не дозволяли
цього робити вони не повідомляли нам як
галузі чи буде взагалі доступна будь-яка
робоча сила
ніби натякаючи Нехай вони з'ясують це
важким шляхом міністрка внутрішніх справ
суела брауерман агресивна ідеологиня
брексіту тут вона на мітингу
ультраконсерваторів зі своєї партії
немає жодної вагомої причини чому ми не
можемо підготувати достатню кількість
водіїв вантажівок м'ясників збирачів
фруктів Будівельників чи зварювальників
береться дає нам можливість побудувати
висококваліфіковану високооплачувану
економіку яка менша залежатиме від низко
кваліфікованої іноземної робочої сили
економісти такі як Джонатан порте
зважають що дефіцит робочої сили це саме
те чого хотів британський уряд
ідея нової політики полягає саме в тому
щоб стиснути сектори які покладалися на
низькооплачувану робочу силу щоб змусити
їх більше інвестувати в технології
навчати і підвищувати кваліфікацію
звісно про те чи спрацює Це поки що
говорити зарано
щоб краще зрозуміти від чого
відштовхуються ідеологи брексіту ми
повинні повернутися до їхнього
колишнього глави Бориса Джонсона Він
обіцяв Золотий вік який настане після
виходу з ЄС і Великобританію де всі
незабаром будуть жити набагато краще в
економічному сенсі і наші бачення
Британії високого оплачувана
низькоподаткова висококваліфікована
високопродуктивна економіка в якій
доходи людей з найнижчими доходами
зростатимуть найшвидшими темпами Ми
хочемо покласти край проблемі
неконтрольованої міграції коли люди
приїжджають на низко кваліфіковану
роботу і тим самим знижують рівень
заробітної плати
його наступне кріші сонек став заклятим
ворогом Джонсона
але Сумах теж прихильник брексіту і його
економічне бачення схоже з тим що у
Джонсона Ця країна Маяк для
найуспішніших найталановитіших людей
світу Ми хочемо залучити найкращих і
найталановитіших з усього світу
приїжджати сюди досліджувати вчитися
створювати нові бізнеси працювати у
наших компаніях
Оце означає для врожаю полуниці це
означає що цю роботу мають виконувати
або високооплачувані британці або роботи
деякі британські ферми вже частково
автоматизовані і на відміну від позиції
Британського уряду щодо дозволів на
роботу тут він доволі щедрий адже на
розвиток нових ідей у сільському
господарстві було виділено близько 230
мільйонів євро
думка Робертсон здає в оренду фермерам
свої перші прототипи і каже що вони
постійно вдосконалюються ми наймаємо
людей щоб вони працювали на глядачами за
роботами ми наймаємо людей які виконують
функцію підтримки вони відповідають за
налаштування роботів на підприємствах
клієнтів і стежить за тим щоб вони
працювали належним чином ця робота може
трохи краще оплачуватися І мабуть вона
більш приваблива ніж збирання фруктів це
може стати гарним рішенням для уряду але
думка не Робертсон Застерігає що ці
роботи досі на стадії Випробування люди
які збирають фрукти будуть потрібні
поряди з машинами і ще деякий час цим
чемберс продовжує обурюватися тим що
уряд не дає працювати іноземним збирачам
які йому потрібні а британці не хочуть
іти на цю роботу для нього роботи усе ще
далеке майбутнє
існують прототипи для збору полуниці і
деякі з них показують непогані перші
результати потенційно вони можуть бути
дуже хорошими але звідки візьметься ка
пітал щоб інвестувати у цю техніку
галузь зараз стоїть на колінах вона
фактично не заробляє грошей які нам
потрібні щоб інвестувати у таку техніку
як і багато британських фермерів він
залежить від іноземної робочої сили
жоден тиск не може цього змінити як би
не хотіли цього прихильники брексі то
британські фермери не можуть обійтися
без іноземців
не просто спорт це мистецтво
принаймні так вважають автори виставки
яка зараз проходить у Брюсселі
на виставці встановлено боксерський ринг
і всіх охочих запрошують долучитися до
бою але це не місце для аперкотів і
нокаутів мета виставки показати молодим
людям мистецтво боксу
без синців під очима
на цьому Ми завершимо сьогоднішній
випуск Європа У фокусі Дякуємо за
перегляд і до зустрічі
[музика]